i want to go before here i want to i
want to go beginning stage to stand up
and i want to find out how
the uh the snl opportunity came about
because i never knew i never knew how
you actually transitioned to snl
oh i got very lucky i was uh i was doing
stand-up for like three
three four years in the city
um and i met amy schumer
and
she let me like open for her on the road
for a little bit and she was like i'm
doing this movie train wreck i'll see if
i can get you like a part in it and i
had like a little
like cameo
and i got to hang with bill hader and
judd apatow and then
when i got home the next day my agent
called me and said bill hader
recommended you for snl really and i was
like why the
[ __ ] would he do that that's i was i was
terrified
how old were you i was like 19 or 20
or about to be 20 and i was like holy
[ __ ] um and then yeah i cuz i i don't
really do characters or anything like
that so i was like i guess maybe i could
be a writer or something and then uh
when you do stand up i did stand up and
when you auditioned for snl
there's
there's no audience it's just like four
people you've auditioned yeah yeah
lauren you have lauren and like three
producers and like higgins yeah and
they're in the pitch black so you can't
see their faces
and you're doing like a five six minute
bit and like occasionally you'll hear
like
yeah
and then then a guy will come out and be
like all right that was great all right
good luck i mean you just leave so
i had uh i had no idea you did stand up
your snl audition was you doing five
yeah i was just talking about like my
mom because i was living with my mom and
stuff so i was just doing jokes like
that so i was like there's no [ __ ]
way
that i would get this i remember i
remember from the conversations around
your name when you got it and i was like
he's a comic i said i know i know it was
a comic because i didn't know you did
characters and stuff so now you telling
me that what did snl ultimately become
in those years and being there i don't
think i figured it out really i think me
and lauren figured it out like two years
ago like how i could work on the show
which is like now i know my spot which
is you know a few things here and there
some rap video or some pre-tape and an
update so like that's that's my role now
okay um but we we really didn't know
cause i just had stand-up bits and i
couldn't do characters or anything like
that um so at first i was like oh [ __ ] i
i'll like get to be here for a year i'll
get fired but like i still like got to
do that and i'll have that credit and
then i could write for like whatever
cartoon network show or like and i'll
just be like i'll be able to work at
least but when you say when you say like
all right we we figured it out two years
ago so years before that i mean we're
talking about a seven-year run right so
you know the five previous to that are
you constantly are you throwing things
at the fire because with snl it's a lot
of okay let's write let's pitch and
let's see what people take and then what
they don't it's like damn they didn't
yeah they didn't take there was a few
writers there that like were very
helpful like this guy streeter seidel
and mikey day they would always look out
for me and like try
uh any week to try a sketch with me and
like once in a while they would hit um
but like i never thought i would be
around that that long at the show and
like you know
there are people you can collaborate
with and pitch stuff but like if you're
not like i'm not like a
uh what the [ __ ] is that like a
groundlings sketch comedy guy they all
are so like they have that type of like
how like comics can hang and like it's
like a little different so i pretty much
didn't really i don't like i don't know
how to write a sketch so i just pretty
much watched
the best people at that job do that with
like zero experience i mean then you
eventually caught on yeah eventually
like i contagion yeah it's really fun
it's like a fun world to like pretend
and stuff but like yeah it took it took
a while do you feel like you're now
finally getting a a grasp on this thing
called entertainment i have no idea what
the [ __ ] is going on ever i just i like
you're so like if your schedule i would
have a panic attack but like i just get
into cars and then get out and then do
what they say and then get back into the
car and then go home but i
i feel like i did find some sort of a
playing field um
where it became my thing but now i feel
like i'm at a place where like the whole
like i'm not supposed to be here
like
type of like you know just downplaying
everything so hard like it's cool to be
self-deprecating like i love it it's
like my thing
but like now i'm at a place where like
i'll do other shows and like you come in
and they have stuff like written for you
and all the dialogue is like i'm a big
[ __ ] idiot
hey let's smoke a doobie
oh yeah
and i'm like
like every joke is just like well you
know me i'm a big [ __ ] idiot
[Music]
you